i i i competed on the uh like what
one time i did a gaming tournament for
my universities yeah i was like
really [ __ ] good at cod um and so i
you're one of those kids yeah i competed
on look so of course you're in of course
you're a call of duty kid
yeah so there was this thing uh oh my
god i mean i'll just go on this whole
tangent then now if you guys are fine
with that
i used to when i was like 15 i won a
[ __ ] ton of card tournaments
because uh modern warfare 3 i don't know
if you ever played did you play modern
warfare
a little bit i stopped at modern warfare
2. okay so modern warfare 3 had this
thing where you could pay
like 40 a year or whatever for like the
the pass for all the maps and then you
could also go on this website that they
had
and they're like tournaments and i
entered one
and they would have a prize for like
okay first ten people get
uh shot glasses of call of duty which is
like
later as [ __ ] to anyone who's over there
yeah yeah 15 year old me was like
whoa i could pour my g fuel into the
world
like you can get something for playing
card so i went to my mates house because
i know that my parents would never let
me pull an all-nighter because bear in
mind these tournaments were
essentially what they were was uh stat
tracking so it would be 24 hours
tournament oh wow right of where you
would just it would be like most kills
in team deathmatch
yeah so you would just go into a normal
team deathmatch and you play
and then it would count how many kills
you had in team deathmatch before and
how many heads so it's basically just
like who can get the highest score
yeah right so basically it was like you
just [ __ ] keep playing yeah and i
[ __ ] you not i played [ __ ] like
capture the flag for like
20 hours straight she's doing this to
win these shots like hell to win these
shot glasses
and i was like crippled after it was
like it was worth it
i came like i i'd i'd won so many
at that time that i was able to go to
sleep confidently knowing that no one
would be able to like overtime
yeah right i think it came like third or
something like so i won and then and
then
one what happened was that it all
changed they changed it so that it was
three hours now
way more manageable yeah so i was like
sweet i can enter all of them and they
were like most
flags defended and captured weird [ __ ]
yeah yeah so sometimes i would be
sitting at my base just waiting for
someone to take my flag
kill them get it back and then just go
back and camp and i would do this [ __ ]
i won like 15 tournaments or something
in the end i won
so my room was full of short glasses
tell you what though what was the best
prize you got
ipad pro at the time oh wow wow ipad
when i was like 17 the brand new ipad at
the time yeah my mom thought that i was
like a drug dealer
because she was like what the [ __ ]
because all this stuff turned up
i won this [ __ ] huge poker set wooden
poker set they only made 250 of them
right and i still have it at my house
because i couldn't sell it it was worth
about
700 pounds jesus it's a wood
box like this big and you open it up and
all these
like wooden poker chips handcrafted card
decks
dealer chips metal immaculate i'll show
you pictures i'll be on screen right now
it's
crazy yeah um and i was doing these for
ages i won like
three skateboard decks i don't
skateboard what the [ __ ]
uh a hoodie two coaster sets that i
still use actually
metal coasters with like cod skulls on
them right [ __ ] cringe
one like wall decals which i couldn't
[ __ ] use i sold most of the stuff on
ebay
um but yeah i won an ipad pro which is
the one time and then
i got banned from competing why because
you were too good
no no no i i so the rules were not well
defined
okay and i was uh i don't know how to
how do i describe
a sneaky [ __ ] you you you bent
the rules too
if i saw an opportunity to win an ipad
pro
i'm going to take the opportunity to win
an ipad pro because it seemed all legit
yeah so
about halfway through these tournaments
i realized okay i'm trying really hard
to win these but i think i can also do
it a lot easier
yeah so basically what i would do is i'd
want a bunch of these tournaments and i
used
that like notoriety from those
tournaments to like recruit people
to come okay so because it would all it
would do is track your stats
right so everyone else on your team
didn't matter so if you had a team that
was coordinated into making
sure that you were the one getting
everything right so you so you basically
smurfed
so what i did was i got like these like
five swedish players yeah and for some
reason the swedish and norwegian dudes
were always [ __ ] amazing
yeah yeah they were way too good and i
promised them if they helped me win all
these tournaments
i would join that clan
i was like negotiating online i would
shout you out i will join
bear in mind i wasn't i wasn't worth
anything but to them they were like yo
he's winning all these tournaments yeah
we gotta get this guy in so uh did you
ever know the game mode like kill
confirmed
no no basically a gamer where you killed
someone and they would drop a tank and
you'd have to collect it
so there's one tournament that was like
whoever gets the most kill confirms in
three hours one yeah so what i did was i
told these guys
like hey kill these dudes and put a
marker on the map of where you dropped
it and don't collect it and i just ran
around collecting them all
i didn't kill anyone and i it was and i
should have not done that because what
ended up happening was like
first place was like 1 200 second place
400. and it raised like a lot of alarm
bells
that doesn't seem fair so
i got away with it for like two or two
or three tournaments before people
started really complaining
yeah and people like this isn't fair
he's winning everything because of this
but then the thing was people started
doing it right so then it was a matter
of everyone was [ __ ] cheating each
other
yeah right and because there were some
real [ __ ] big boy prizes
there was a jeep one of them jesus which
i
[ __ ] i was like 10 points off winning
a [ __ ] jeep at the age of 16.
never mind i was i was winning all these
prizes under my dad's name yeah because
they wouldn't ship it to you if you uh
they also may fill out tax forms which i
couldn't even legally fill out which i
what did you tell your dad that you were
like filling out i was like dad i've won
a bunch of stuff
and it's gonna it's gonna turn up to the
house in a ups fan about 20 items
i need you to pretend that you won them
that
and they were very visibly like what
yeah and then they were like okay
i guess yeah yeah and so the thing that
got me banned right
from these tournaments yeah there was
this one prize
that was you know the movie battleship
with featuring rihanna yeah yeah yeah
horrible they were promoting the movie
battleship yeah one of the prizes was
you could rent out a whole movie theater
and take all your friends
to get drinks
i thought to myself the amount of street
cred i'll get from this is
immersion this is an outstanding move
that
no one will experience i was like okay
okay okay okay bear in mind
i have to say people might call [ __ ]
on this whole thing but i was literally
eight hours a day addicted to cod so
straight up like this is what i made for
me to do this so
what i had was this was the team
deathmatch tournament i remember this so
vividly
and uh in team death manchester to kill
them yeah so what i would do is i would
ask my friends to go around with riot
shields
and card you ever play it yeah yeah
don't kill anyone okay yeah
if you can trap them in a corner tell me
where they are i'll come over and pop
them in the head
right so what we would do is right i
coordinated mafia
it was literally so you how what what
what like incentive did you give them to
like follow
everything [ __ ] nothing i was keeping
things holy
i was keeping this order myself i never
ever told them once i was gonna help
them do it right
i was just like i'm just gonna take the
prizes and you guys can help me they
were like
all right it's good that sounds like a
good deal
i do remember thinking so the swedish
dudes they had a reason right because
they said i would join their team i did
join their team and we went a lot of
tournaments but yeah
a lot of the other people who helped me
out had no incentive whatsoever i just
wanted to
have fun yeah yeah and it was
entertaining as [ __ ] to just go in
and do this yeah and i i won some of
these tournaments on my own but i was
sweating my ass off like i would have to
like really play my best and so i
thought why do that one i can just
get it secured i mean it's in the rules
there's no rules
i was like why am i sweating when i can
just guarantee the w right like
so yeah i did that and by that time
they'd implemented a feature where you
could see
like a heat map of what was happening
right people were starting to see that
it was like
75 kills to me zero zero zero zero with
my teammates right
and people were like hmm
that doesn't seem like a normal game of
team deathmatch
he got a nuke and so
what happened was that they wanted to
make an example out of me and they were
like
no more doing this no one else is
allowed to do this we've banned this
from happening
right yeah and so they banned me from
doing it and i remember i spoke to the
other because there was like four of us
who won all of these tournaments right
right and the other two were like 30
year old men who worked in like
construction companies and this is like
all they would do in their speed time
and i felt bad for them because i was
like a 15 year old kid being like i'm
gonna take the money that you probably
need
i don't need this [ __ ] i'm gonna take it
i love how they banned you
and then you kind of became you like v
for vendetta
it's like i wanted to make a statement
and i got banned for it
the one year after that i was so [ __ ]
bitter because i was like
it wasn't in their [ __ ] rules they
just did it to make an example out of me
the website shut down five months ago
yeah that website failed five months
after i was like yeah [ __ ] you wow
they emailed me like two years later
being like hey could you fill out those
tax forms we sent you i'm like
and i just never did yeah i'm like what
are you going to do i live in a
different country what are you going to
do
i was 15 at the time
it was the official call of duty website
it was okay if you wanted to go and
track your stats you would have to go do
this and you would
pay like 10 10 pounds extra yeah a year
to get access to the tournament man
you're that guy who just tries to cheat
every system in life
oh dude yeah if there's like overall
yeah yeah
yeah it's like if there's like loopholes
or corners to be cut i'll just always
find them because it's like
yeah like that's it works smarter right
yeah like why would i
work harder when i can just do things
easy right i mean
i was not cheating there was no rule
against what i was doing and they
[ __ ]
they banned me because i was too good at
their own game i wasn't cheating
i was just bending the rules yeah i was
outsmarting i was
so scared i was outsmarting the system
i'm so [ __ ] sad because like your
honor i was outsmarting the system
the only thing the only true okay so i
had that ipad i got mad mileage out of
that ipad that was worth it all that
ipad as well i can imagine
like two thousand dollars yeah yeah so
that was amazing and my mum was like
still like even after was like hmm you
got an ipad yeah you're doing drugs did
you send dick pics to somebody connor
how are you drugs on the side are you
waiting son are you
that was such a fun time that was like
great that was so fun
i love doing that because i just won so
much i wish i won the good stuff like
the jeeps yeah
that dude that would have been a mad
flex if you want to just do that i was
just busy watching anime
yes yeah i remember the jeep i wasn't
close to winning but there was one time
where they had uh quad bikes
about like you know like 10 grand maybe
yeah yeah i came [ __ ] fourth and it
was for the top three and i came fourth
by draw oh wow so i drawn for it i
didn't get it because of that i was so
annoyed i was like mom
i didn't get the quad bikes i can't
believe it
would you even be able to use the quad
bikes i suppose in wales
plenty of people to sell them yeah i
think like four out of the 30 people in
my class had quad bikes like it's
everyone had quad bikes for some reason
those were the guys who like came in the
top three
i was like i see you got it that's how
they got it
i mean it was yeah i mean i i think it
would have been problematic if i got
that though because i'm not sure how
much my dad could have bullshitted
because i imagine there would have been
a lot more forms involved when it came
to a qualified
like ups isn't just dropping off a quad
bike insurance and everything right yeah
did he ever find out what how you got
those yeah yeah they knew they were just
like the first few tournaments that i
said i won they didn't believe me
yeah until because all of the stuff
turned up at once like these 20 because
i won i think around 15 tournaments
total right
and they all turned up at the same day
the prizes and my mom was like in
complete disbelief she was like you
weren't lying
what is this wow i wish i could give my
mom on to a test she probably has a
better memory of it than me because i
don't remember very well
you you are the epitome of i am winning
dad like